how is everyone it's good to be here and
it's really uh it's really an honor I
guess to address the the fun fact that
Jared mentioned you know all my kids do
have an R in their name but that's only
because they share my last name of
Turner so they have two R's
I guess my daughter's name is Reese and
she has an extra one so that's good yeah
it's it's such an honor to be here to be
part of community everyone's really been
so wonderful and I think that's one of
the great reasons like I really really
love being a part of it and I'm really
humbled to be here to speak and also to
be a part of like the many great
speakers that are here today I sit back
in awe listening to what others have to
say so to stand up here is is really
unique I know I'm I only have a certain
amount of time so let's make sure I hit
through everything I hope to talk about
the first thing is I do want to thank
Jared this was Jared last year I gave
him an army math frisbee there is a lot
of frisbee that goes on at the United
States Military Academy at West Point
and the army math department frisbee
team seems to be a year in year out
winter so I got to Pat myself on the
back for that so let's see my my purpose
today is to talk through a little bit
about what West Point is and and how we
use our and what I want to do to do that
I'm gonna talk about a couple things
first will be you know who we are as
West Point what we do and in the way we
apply it in our own learning so first of
all what what is West Point West Point's
a four-year university where we train
cadets both in academic military and
physically in order to be leaders of our
nation for the for the United States
Army
so we have very high standards for
admission very high standards both
character development and all through
these these pillars and also at once you
graduate West Point at the end of it you
leave with a bachelor's degree in some
field but but also you're commissioned
as a second lieutenant the army so in
each one of these pictures kind of
represents you know we we want Scholar
we want war
and we want to want athletes and I
include the football picture because you
know we went through a really dry spell
for a long time of not being that good
it really started back when I graduated
in 2007 we lost a navy like 13 or 14
years in a row but running to your
winning streak and things are trending
up so it's good Sean talked about time
series analysis I don't know how this
applies but I think we've we've turned a
corner so so that's good so who are the
faculty at West Point this is just kind
of a snippet of some of my peers we
exist where there's 77 of us that teach
cadets about 30% of civilians all the
civilians have a PhD the military
faculty are split between PhD and
masters people with master's degree
people with master's degrees and I'm one
of those and I list these peers here
there's a few more if they end up
watching this video I'm gonna feel kind
of bad that I didn't include them but
these are the ones my friends who we
kind of collaborate a lot together using
our is we've kind of embraced it and
part of the the luckiness I guess of it
is will you all you know are started
getting really big when most of us are
in grad school so we've been able to
kind of leverage it and move forward
into applying it to the curriculum and
here at West Point all right cool so Who
am I I am a 2007 graduate of West Point
I commissioned as a second lieutenant
into the Corps of Engineers where I
served for about eight years with trips
to Hawaii
Missouri white sands Georgia New York
Ohio a lot of different places and I've
loved it I loved it all and I've had
short pit stops in both Iraq and
Afghanistan which were some really
growing experiences for me but after
those seven years I applied to teach at
West Point they accepted me conditional
that I completed a master's degree at
The Ohio State University so not oh here
we go
Yeah right there JD thanks thanks so I
would also like to point out we at West
Point finally beat Navy after the 13-14
year dry spell the first year I showed
up to
hi-oh state we won the national
championship in football so should you
as I see some Buckeyes around that's
right yeah that's right I oh so you know
if your team's on a dry spell maybe you
could use me your ph.d program or
something someday I'm for hire I guess
but when that was complete I I showed up
at West Point where I now teach
statistics introductory statistics as a
core course and one of the electives so
let's see
during my growth as in our user I read
the book doing data data science and it
had a quote that really stuck with me
and it seems to continue to be true as I
learn more and more and it's something
like this paraphrase being a data
scientist is where you learn more and
more about more and more until you
essentially know nothing about it it is
about know nothing about everything and
I feel like the more I I know and the
longer I'm in this community I seem to
know a lot of nothing
so it's what's great to be here is to to
learn and rub shoulders with a lot of
you guys and with that Jared didn't
mention a little bit you know West Point
has a few our heroes of people in this
community who have come out to talk with
our cadets and it's great you know Jared
Emily JD and addy Rob or both coming out
here in a week d Rob's coming out a week
but everyone else has been to West Point
to talk and really had a big impact on
not only our faculty and awareness about
the power that R has but also impact our
cadets and kind of stroke some of their
passions here now I know a lot of the
guys like that have up here and some
other guys that have done a lot of work
in the art community really have you
know helped us to do a lot of stuff that
we wouldn't be able to do otherwise
so a saying comes to mind I'm sure most
of you've heard it you're standing on
the shoulders of giants right I feel a
lot of times though it feels more like
this where you're like holding on for
dear life as you're progressing in your
experience so the the tough thing with
it is if the risk of selling myself
short and I'm just going to briefly talk
about this
is when you're in the presence of so
many people that are good at so many
things you can feel kind of like an
impostor so a lot of times you feel like
a cat trying to be a penguin and you
kind of blend in and just keep your
mouth shut and smile but what I do have
to say on this note is the you know the
people that that I just had up here on
the on the slide right here and the
whole community have actually never they
never make people feel that way
so the newcomers in here have room to
grow and it helps really grow the
community and it's really helped us at
West Point so we're in debt to you for
that so thank you very much
all right so where does our me math fit
in the curriculum at West Point being a
four-year education everything in the
top row of green all the greens the core
courses at West Point the top row there
are the four math courses the four core
math course is a modeling course to
calculus and a probability and
statistics course now in the operations
research curriculum all the yellow is
math courses and all the red is systems
engineering but the more important
question is you know where does our fit
in in all this and we really have
involved our heavily in these courses
not only the introductory probability
and statistics course but in many of the
o'er courses that you see there you know
I tried different colors to highlight
that and blue is about as good as it
could get I could try P but I couldn't
just bring myself to it you know black
clashed so hopefully you can you can see
the the highlight but West Point uses
are in five different ways in course
organization we also have an outreach
program of science technology
engineering and math where we go out
across the country to proselytize math
if you will across the country we use it
as a teaching tool we hope it make
decisions informed decision making in
the army and also we use it to improve
the learning experience I'm going to go
through examples of each one of these
first things first we use it as a course
organization tool and as you can see
here on this slide nice it comes up
perfect this is an example of a course
syllabus that we use for the course I
teach em a 256 it's the advanced
introduction to statistics course and
it's in our markdown so our cadets can
come in here and you see if I could pull
this off here it is our cadets can come
in here
and I can you know click through you
know there's block one so they can see
Oh for less than one what am I supposed
to do and it gives them you know videos
to go to suggested problems in WebAssign
whatnot and actually you know if I want
to know what graded events I have coming
up they can go through all this to
include all the way down here at the
bottom you know supplement supplementary
material to help them you know with our
let me see I got to get back over here
on this side don't wanna mess this up
click there we go alright now we have a
stem outreach stem outreach program that
we where we go across the country and we
involve middle schoolers in math and we
try to provide it in an inspirational
way and one of the things that we do and
I'm gonna have to refresh my shiny app
that I have here on this screen is here
we go we bring them in and say there's
40 or so elementary school folks and we
create a bunch of nodes and then we kind
of pull the audience like hey which one
of you live on this street and when we
do that we can come in here and we can
add edges to show like hey person one
and six or one in five are are together
for some reason they show some sort of
relationship so we're able to build this
interactively with them on the spot and
we use shiny to help us do that so it's
really been a big hit with the middle
schoolers because then they can see the
similarities and jump to adjacency
matrix and all sort of things to
hopefully inspire this type of learning
as they grow up and get older all right
back over here ok now on day one this
seems kind of an an easy concept but we
I bring my cadets in and I use shiny to
kind of wow that my told us this is all
built in our and what we do is we input
the cadets hometown so when they
introduce himself to the class they say
hey I'm from Kerrville Texas I click the
search button
and it brings up you know each one of
their hometowns as you can see as they
it goes out online scrapes their
population and then it begins to update
the mean and median and the trimmed mean
so I'm able on less than one to talk
about hey what's more representative of
the sample is it than the
is the median the trimmed mean and you
know we always have a a few that kind of
throw us off because you have all those
outliers but what's fun too is to show
this map overall the cadets live and I
have to update the map here before it
works and you can see where all the
cadets in one of my sections live notice
where I got quite a few Texans in there
I happen to be from Texas so I'm very
very proud that we have that type of
representative representation but all
these northeasterners I don't know
what's up with you guys alright so
another class that I teach is
sabermetrics it's the study of baseball
at least statistics as it relates to
baseball and that doesn't look good
let's see if I can make it make it work
and of course they all need to be
reloaded well they may all not work now
oh here we go good news alright so this
what I've done for my courses I've
offered bonus points to anyone who can
beat me at my version of fantasy
baseball so they go out and they select
ten players at large they can share them
and base off the amount of total bases
they get minus strikeouts they can you
know get a score so what this does is it
really generates interest in modeling
you know future base production for for
uh you know different athletes now I am
gonna kind of tell him myself as I show
this list of who's winning by total
score you'll notice my name dusty Turner
is right at the bottom which is really
kind of embarrassing since I came up
with the game there was a flaw in the
model that I built and that I in I
inadvertently subtracted or I added
strikeouts instead of subtracting them
so the fact that I'm actually beating
anyone is a no small miracle shame on me
right okay and also you know we get in
some more more fun things where we we
teach the central limit theorem so this
is a tool that we passed out to the
cadets where they can see you know as
sample size increases you know what
happens to the distribution of your mean
and it and it illustrates you know
sample size gets larger you know the
distribution of x-bar approaches normal
which is really fun you know for the
cadets get involved with you know we
have different distributions to that
ones binomial the gamma distributions a
lot of fun I'll just drag it out there
we go
neat all right
all right so another tool that we've
worked with - we also not only teach
with R but we like to help make
decisions inside the Academy and in
surprising you know in the military that
we at least in the Army sometimes we
value like who can pick up the heaviest
rucksack and run into the wall the
hardest and who can do the most pushups
but surprisingly we sometimes try to
inform our decisions with a little bit
of analysis and what you'll see here is
the admissions department sent a request
for us to do and I'm not gonna be able
to zoom in just based off how it works
but to do some analysis on certain
demographics which I'm not gonna go into
detail about it a might not load but you
can kind of see the representation of
different demographics by West Point
across the army and it's clearly not
going to load so that's oh there it is
and so you can see by congressional
district how the representation is and I
can kind of zoom in so this helps our
admissions department you know make
decisions based off of the
representation alright and then the last
example I'm going to show is operational
support so hurricane maria it's
september last year hit in Puerto Rico
so we sent a task force down to try and
you know try to help the folks in Puerto
Rico
and general Buchanan a three-star
general in charge of the command wanted
to know as quickly as possible hey how
are the population how's the population
reacting to our relief efforts so using
a lot of the tools you know holding on
to the neck of the giraffe I applied a
lot of the stuff that D rob has this
book about and we created a shiny app to
interact with tweets as they were sent
from Puerto Rico and apply sentiment
tool to see like the positive and
negative connotations and we did more
than just this but essentially what it
showed is like over time and when
certain events happen what was the
public's reaction to that and you can
see the each tweet is represented by a
little orange dot and you can click on a
tweet and you know see what said person
and this one has a sentiment score of
zero so I guess he was neutral about
whatever he was talking about in this
experience all right so quickly what I
want to talk about last is
how we improve the cadet education
experience essentially the problem
statement I went too far
darn there's my joke which is another
joking of itself so essentially there's
a long-standing tradition at West Point
where we think that if you group cadets
by likability in a classroom not
likeability like I like you but similar
ability you will learn better
so effectively these cadets if they're
you know smart cadet in the glasses
versus silly cadet they don't learn as
well together as opposed to these cadets
learn well together in these cadets
learn well together so what's great
about our course is we have oh I gotta
give credit to these two handsome
looking gentlemen who helped me on this
project
major Collins and major place but our
course consists of about five hundred
students we have eleven instructors and
seventeen cadets per classroom so this
is pretty structured the person who runs
this course agreed to let us split up
half the cadets viability and half the
cadets are sectioned at random and then
afterwards compare the difference and I
think we exist in a unique environment
that we can do that and hopefully inform
learning at other universities so what
do I have over here so essentially what
we did we developed a model to predict
how well cadets do we split them up into
a control and treatment group and then
we examine the experiment and then
evaluated the results now I'm gonna kind
of blow through this pretty quickly
essentially what we evaluated them on
was you know inputs into the model where
your previous performance at Westpoint
and also the track that you take through
the Academy because we have the Jedi
track if you come in with a strong
background all the way down to the rock
math where it's like adding and
subtracting and things like that which
are clearly I need help with
so we use the carrot package I like max
I've seen this this carrot up there a
time or two we did some data preparation
and then we fit three different models a
linear model a lasso and a random forest
and when we shook it all out you can see
the relative variable importance all
really essentially was your core average
in your previous math skill which
shouldn't be all that surprising so we
and you can see the performance of each
one of these models we unsolved all of
them in kind of a simple way just by
taking the predictions and dividing by
three since we had three models and then
we split you up in that way so the top
17 cadets went to the top class and next
17 all the way on down the down the ways
and then we had our random section now
the results as you can tell on the
predicted axis versus the actual grade
you are colored by if you were randomly
assigned your colored pinkish and you
were blue or green if you're by ability
group and to the naked eye
it looks like it doesn't really matter
who you're with
you're you're just kind of gonna do what
you were gonna do which are I think
someone earlier talked about having
negative results so this is some some
negative results right and you can see
here actually we might have even hurt
you if by putting you with people of
likability because your mean average
your mean grade was lower than if you
were sectioned by if you were in ability
group section you did worse than if you
were at random I got that backwards if
you were put at random you did better
than if you were section by ability
there you go
and the confidence interval includes 0
which means yeah we we can't really tell
if there's a difference between the two
of you now what if we looked at it by
ability level what you see side-by-side
here is if you were in an ability group
and at the top or if you were randomly
selected and at the top and how well did
you do versus your peers and it looks
kind of the same thing where you didn't
really perform better no matter what
group that you were placed in now we
could keep going around and around
oh yes here's a pairwise comparisons and
as you can see ability level eight comes
up significantly different
but without a bonferroni correction or
anything like that I would say that this
isn't part of the you know the false
positive that should be expected now I
could keep going right and I could hack
this one way after another to try to get
some results out of this but essentially
we've had enough P hacking here I think
it's pretty conclusive that you know
you're gonna learn how you're gonna
learn no matter who you're with which is
kind of comforting as a learner and lets
you off the hook as an instructor as
well so it's really my honor to be here
I I'm kind of embarrassed because I had
a different version up here where I had
a slide of a run I did this morning in
the run I ran in the shape of an R in
the New York City streets and I must
have dropped out I open an old version
my fault but it's truly an honor to
speak to you today thank you so much
thank you for this community Thank You
Jared and I look forward to chatting
with you afterwards thank you
and I'm okay